LLED UP AFTEKSGIVIBUWE GOT A
NGSPYER OF TURKEY FROM
BIGOTRY ABOUT ILHAN OMAR.
SHK TORE
, N'T HAVE
VER AN DECIDED TOL
IT'S JUST HER STAFFERS O
LK FOR HER.E'S NOH IN PERSON.
UNHAS SENSE RED
SOOLY HE UT.
AT BOEBERT SAI T. A HOMOPHOBIC P
IS TH
.
SOMEBODY OUGHT TO TELL HIM SO HE
RK.
>> SHE WAS A T
HEDMISAR
EFFOTORAGE IONSSH
BIED
NAZITOA COUNTY AND
NGTON THAT SHES ON ON
CAPITOL HILL. L RR FIREAND IN C.
TH CAUSEFROM
D THE
A YOU CAN EVEN FIND MOCKING TH
GLORIFICATION
OLTH A J
WASHINGTON.
ERTE
R THAT.
RE OF PAUL GOSAROMEO THE TRUM
WAS CE POTHOP ANIME SHOWING TACR
McCARTHY HAS GONFROMLAUMP FOR J
RESPONSIBILIORRESS BB  S
E MOB WHEN HE SAW THES
NI HED
NOT RONALD RN AND NOT LDTRUMP A
WHETHECOME HOUSE SPEAKE E KNT
HAS LEM INUR CONREHE DOESN'T HF
HAVE THE RIGHTOWHEENCH
N
HER WAY TOCH AOP HASEEREMARK
C SYMPATHIZERS.
THE REST OK SHOW UCAND TE
FLOWSE DIRECTBLR LEADCHIOD
.TTENHOUSE,
THE PICTURE OF KIM JONG-UN BEHI.
MES  FREAK SUSN FIGHTINGVEE  ASS
BU
LI
A
K'RSAYING
ESE .
REALLYIT SOUNDS LIKE HE'S ON
TOPEKEVIN McCARTHY OBJECT TO
Y DO.AS WE'TH FRIENDS FOR THE
HOLIDAYS, ASK URSELVAR
HATEFUL, VIOLETHINK SO.Y, I WOUG